you know what Maleficent you were the
one who decided to have a kid it's not
Mouse fault that she had to grow up on
the Isle of the lost but you did nothing
but use her and never showed her any
role of and karela your son is not your
servant Carlos is this sweetest kid but
you basically made him your personal
Butler you and all your villain friends
make terrible parents life on the Isle
is pretty much rough for a VK we're
going to take a look at the messed up
origin stories of the descendants
villain kids at some point as kids we
all might disappoint our parents but now
seems to do it all the time she wants to
be as evil as her mom Maleficent but she
always falls short Maleficent is always
upset with now in some ways she wants
now to be just like her but in other
ways she wants to remain the evilest
villain and doesn't want to now as
competition she just doesn't understand
that it was her actions as a villain
that landed them on the Isle of the Lost
in the first place the Evil Queen is a
little bit better of a mom when she
wants Evie to get married to a prince
but she doesn't appreciate Evie for how
smart and talented she is she expects
Evie to be just as vain as her but the
Evil Queen doesn't value anything except
money and beauty
it's amazing that Evie turned out as
sweet as she did Jay actually seems to
have a good relationship with his dad
Jafar
but Jafar has taught him to be a thief
and he's proud of his thieving skills
that doesn't send the right message to
his son at all and then there's Carlos
his origin story is so sad you have to
be a special sort of evil to use puppies
to make fur coats Cruella Deville
doesn't even treat Carlos like her son
she treats him like her servant and an
unpaid servant at that he has to die at
moms hair and take care of her clothes
and she even makes him scrape the
bunions off her feet
you guys seriously disgust him in
descendants - he tells mouth that he was
usually the one being yelled at on the
aisle
his mom was always so mean damn poor
Carlos Varela also blames dogs for being
stuck on the aisle so she lies to Carlos
she tells him that dogs are vicious
killer
that leads to him being terribly
terrified of dogs despite never having
met one on the Isle if that wasn't bad
enough
Corelli used to make Carlos sleep on the
floor of her coat room which was lined
with bear traps that means that poor
Carlos couldn't get a good night's sleep
without fearing for his life we don't
know too much about the other V Ches
lives but they definitely don't have
happy relationships with their parents
uma is the daughter of Ursula her mother
used to be a powerful sea witch now she
owns a diner and forces uma to work
their verse Allah loves to watch soap
operas and hardly ever leaves her room
she forces uma to run her restaurant and
has no issues with keeping all the
profits for herself
arey hook is the son of Captain Hook he
doesn't talk a lot about his dad but we
can infer that he really wants to make
his dad proud
he used a fake hook hand to try to be
like his father we wonder if Captain
Hook is as hard to please as Maleficent
we have a feeling he is life on the Isle
of the Lost is tough even if you have a
good parent King Adam and Queen Belle
cut the Isle completely off from ours on
our Adan is a rich country where
everyone has what they need but they
don't even provide the aisle with basic
necessities it's clear that there isn't
a lot of food on the aisle there's also
a lot of poverty which leads to a bunch
of stealing the buildings are falling
down and totally trashed and a lot of
the kids look like they can't get a bath
and a hot meal this is no easy way to
live they also don't have many of life's
simple pleasures
the vks don't even get to taste
chocolate until they are headed to our
dine the magic barrier keeps the isle
completely isolated we can't blame the
BK's for thinking at auradon is full of
snobs it's not the kids fault that they
are stuck on the Isle and let's be
honest it's pretty messed up the king
and queen keep the descendants in such
terrible conditions for really glad Ben
sees things differently the descendants
novels give us a much deeper look at
life on the Isle the schools are run by
villains like Lady Tremaine
that's Cinderella's wicked stepmother
and the vks are not getting a great
education they take classes on how to be
evil they can even take a class called
advanced evil schemes and nasty tricks
we've got your school doesn't have that
class they are encouraged to design an
ultimate project where they do something
truly wicked look we've all had bad
but none of them ever have encouraged us
to be evil ceviches have no good role
models on the aisle
once mal evj and Carlos are out from
under their parents thumbs they learned
that life really isn't that bad they
turn into awesome smart and caring
people despite their upbringing now we
do want to know if Maleficent is going
to stay a lizard forever do you think
the parents will learn their lesson in
descendants 3 or will they stay the same
let us know your theories in the
comments thanks for watching like this
video and subscribe to the things for
more awesome content we'll see you next
time
[Music]